hey if you haven't already got it get
yourself a copy of answer the Internet
the card game it's available right now
in the link in the bio or you can get a
bar salal Mart Amazon or Spencer Gifts
play along with us it's good hey guys
I'm jo koy and I'm back to answer some
more of those Internet questions let's
go if you could be homeless in any city
where would you choose oh my god Vegas
are you kidding me Vegas because you
could double down yeah I mean you just
get some money and then you go right to
the slot machine come on come on Jesus
Christ come on man I just that's very
smart very smart you ever seen a
homeless guy stick like 895 in quarters
on [ __ ] black let's go would you
rather always be hard or never be able
to get hard are you is that even a
question
wait what kind of hard though like
hardcore Oh dick okay yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah thanks yeah I thought you
bet like come in hard you lay a [ __ ]
with me no no okay yeah my dick hard
yeah okay so yeah yeah always hard I'd
rather just walk around just hang my
coat on it yeah I mean I'm gonna go
outside for a second and then just pull
my dick off my coat I'd take my coat off
with my dick when I say take my dick off
my coat imagine pulling your coat off of
your hard dick where's my keys Oh on the
same hook how much is too much for a
height difference in a relationship oh
[ __ ]
any height your girls should always be
looking up to you always are you hungry
honey you want to make love what are we
gonna do tonight never ever should your
girl be like hey I'm starving
let's get pizza
are we gonna see a movie or what I
promise honey let me go grab my coat off
my dear if you were taken hostage five
years ago what surprise
would you most yeah plus I can't see I
got old people's eyes they were terribly
yeah what would surprise you what would
what would surprised you most about the
world Oh first and foremost go [ __ ]
yourself what would surprise you most
about the world today five years ago oh
[ __ ] um that there's adults on tick tock
[ __ ] stop okay
hey man if you're 25 and you're on tick
tock shoot yourself in the face last
thing I want to see is my dad on tick
tock alone oops I did it again
how long would it take you to eat your
own bodyweight in hot dogs oh [ __ ]
well one I love hot dogs the best
I love Coney Island's I love Chicago
style but I can only eat one dude I'm
not kobayashi [ __ ]
cook you son of a [ __ ] it would take
meters it'll take me about 10 years 10
years I can't eat how many pounds of my
weight
I weigh uh you know 172 until my neck
falls down oh by the way I want everyone
to know that's watching this right now I
do have a double chin I just colored the
bottom beard black you're welcome fellas
don't show that double chin make it look
like a shadow that's my tip to you would
you rather have your mom send you a new
home man
would you rather have your mom send you
a nude or have her send all your friends
and the Oh God [ __ ] um I don't know
where to go with that one I guess send
it to me
sends me I've seen it I came out of that
I came out of it I did I came out of it
man
I did it was my home for nine months I
know that I know what it looks like it's
it was comfortable it was good living oh
how much money would it take for me to
streak on it on the field during an NFL
game oh I'll do that [ __ ] for free I I
would do that [ __ ] for free but then
what happens you get a red like you just
get banned right you get banned from the
that's fine that's fine but then again
I'm hanging my coat you tackle me man
you face the coat who is the worst group
of fans ah [ __ ] man I don't want to get
in trouble for this man soccer fans and
I would give a [ __ ] what team no one
cares
no one [ __ ] cares the thing is I have
a friend that plays professional soccer
he's gonna hate that I said this Neil
Etheridge I love you I love you to death
man you're the [ __ ]
you're the best play you're the best
looking player in the world hands down
go look him up you guys Neil Etheridge
following I'm just saying I went to my
son's soccer game when he was five and
it's the same score that you had zero
one if you could pick any sidekick who
would it be that my friend is easy it
would be Green Hornet wait not Green
Hornet what was his name Kaito Kaito
from the Green Hornet
yeah Bruce Lee Kato
I want my driver to know kung foo
how dope is that get me there on time
and have beat the [ __ ] out of people
would you kill baby Hitler if would you
kill baby Hitler if it had to be in a
very gruesome way uh there is no
gruesome way when you're killing baby
Hitler alright first of all no baby
should have a square mustache oh yeah I
can kick baby Hitler in the [ __ ]
throat with steel-tipped boots oh you do
know you know all you do know you
already know a little baby yeah you
little baby Hitler give the Jews like
what the [ __ ] did you say kill the Jews
you [ __ ] you baby Hitler say it again
that's his first words it's not mama or
Dada yo dude what up what the [ __ ] did
you say baby Hitler young dudes
I don't know why I mean Cartman baby
Hitler funny
if you want 300 million dollars what are
the first three things you would buy oh
that's easy
one uh an airplane right duh and I want
it big enough to fit my Maybach what do
I Drive do you really want to have a
Tesla X and and I bought that right when
he came out so that's when it was really
expensive and then I also have I have a
Tesla Roadster coming in January so uh
next card if there was a snail following
you
for the rest of your life and if you
touched it you die how long could you
survive snail has a GPS on you he knows
he's got intelligence he's super smart
guys it was touched yeah where you go he
knows where you're going
she obviously still super slow
but the rest of your life he's Jesus oh
thanks for explaining that card cuz I
had no idea what I was reading and I'm
not even trying to be funny
hello would it take me to survive I
could go I can go a hundred years easy
I'm just good at oh I'm good I'm good
cut - just [ __ ] dead just nail pissed
across my face